much quickly checking back in live in  washington dc we mentioned at the  beginning of the program  uh president biden was talking about  some of the efforts being made to try  and fight the pandemic  here he is signing more of those  executive orders that we talked about on  in skylar henry's report as well uh they  have to do with the pandemic  mandates for wearing the the mask uh in  public  public transportation interstate travel  other aspects of the beginnings of the  vaccine effort and the  mass wearing effort to try and deal with  the coronavirus uh this just the first  full day for the biden administration  they've already taken action with  executive orders  on the horizon of course is the efforts  that'll have to get congressional  approval as well  when it comes to the 1.9 trillion dollar  relief package so that's what's  happening in washington dc we'll keep an  eye on that we have more details for you  at 8newsnow.com